so the meaning of this country do not
exist to inform you obviously but to
mislead you on behalf of the people in
power so it's not surprising the footage
you're about to see has been hidden in
years it just surfaced in a PBS special
of all places it shows the mayor of
Washington DC Muriel Bowser and Tony
fauci in 2021 visiting residents in a
black neighborhood in DC to push the
covet vaccine and you can assess for
yourself how well that went
so this is Ward 8.
it's the typical social determinants of
Health where they don't get good medical
care they have a high degree of HIV High
degree of coven 19. the lowest level of
vaccination so I'm not going to be
lining up taking a shot on a vaccination
for something that wasn't clear in the
first place and then you all create a
shot and miraculous time it takes years
to thank you well it used to take years
if it allowed thousands of people like
you don't get vaccinated you're going to
let this virus continue to percolate in
this country and in this world something
like the common flu then right you gonna
pass yeah definitely because when you
start talking about paying people to get
vaccinated when you start talking about
incentivizing things to get people
vaccinated it's something else going on
with that I don't keep you anymore it's
okay
y'all campaign is about fear it's about
inciting fear in people you all attack
people with fear that's what this
pandemic is
so great the people of wardate may be
poor but they're not stupid notice Tony
fauci gazed at them like he's walking
through the zoo with contempt and a
little bit of fear
so he kept getting questions like this
from the poor but not stupid people of
Ward 8 in DC one lady asked Tony facci
if the vaccine would prevent her from
getting covid which is the most basic of
all questions here's how fat she
responded I heard that it doesn't
um cure it and it doesn't
um stop you from getting it no so on the
very very very rare chance that you do
get it even if you're vaccinated it's a
very you don't even feel sick it's like
you don't even know you got infected
it's very very good at protecting you
so it turns out the lady in the tank top
was a lot closer to the Target than Mr
Tony fauci the highest paid Federal
bureaucrat in the world Raymond Arroyo
is the author of the unexpected light of
Thomas Alva Edison and we're happy to
have him join us tonight Raymond thanks
so much for coming on you work in DC
you're familiar with the city what do
you make of this amazing and highly
amusing tape well you know first of all
this is on American Masters Tucker now
when I watch American Masters I want to
see Sammy Davis Jr Martha Graham but now
we have Tony fauci the master of
deception maybe but not not the mass an
American Master he also this crew
followed him Tucker for 23 months like
his Beyonce you know every move has to
be captured by the camera it is a
remarkable document though of the common
sense of people even in very poor
communities they were saying what we
were hearing from epidemiologists in
viral colleges all over the country very
early on mainly these are leaky vaccines
they don't prevent infection or spread
and that man on the on the stoop you got
to give them props there's a moment
where he says you are incentivizing this
you're paying us to take this and that
made him squeamish about it there's a
moment in the documentary Tucker where
behind fauci they have a car and on the
car it says win me so all it costs to
win this car is to allow them to give
you the jab offer your arm I'm sorry Mr
Rogers neighborhood is a lot more
friendly than Dr fauci's you don't want
him coming knocking on your door that's
right what's so interesting is I spent
my life in that City diagonally across
it in the rich part of the city right
where nobody had any questions about the
government's motives here it's
interesting in the poorest most
crime-ridden part of the city everybody
had a kind of gut skepticism that turned
out to be well warranted yeah well and
look when we're not the Cookie Monster
but the booster monster comes looking
for you you better hide hide the kids
but I love that people were willing to
confront him but the the arrogance the
um the the arrogance toward these people
was striking from fauci he already had a
Disney plus documentary now we got to
get PBS in on the action come on I love
it all my Harvard educated neighbors are
like oh I've seen says it's okay okay
and this guy doesn't have a job he's
like what no yeah we're not doing that I
don't think so
God bless you so great Common Sense
Tucker it will save us
Raymond Arroyo thanks so much thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight